J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour. C'est un sujet que je voulais couvrir depuis bientôt trois ans et ça y est, je sors enfin l'épisode sur les troubles du comportement alimentaire, comme promis.
On a tous entendu parler d'anorexie, de boulimie, mais pour autant, on est rarement bien informé sur ces troubles au sujet desquels il y a pas mal d'idées reçues et de stéréotypes.
J'ai enfin pu trouver et réunir deux invités pour en parler. Vous allez voir qu'il y a à la fois un psychiatre spécialisé en la matière, le plus grand spécialiste en Belgique francophone, m'a dit Olivia Klein,
mais aussi une youtubeuse directement concernée par les troubles du comportement alimentaire qui a su partager avec nous son expérience, son point de vue en la matière.
J'étais très content de les recevoir tous les deux pour pouvoir croiser les regards. Concrètement, l'une était en France et l'autre était à ma gauche. Donc,
il a fallu un peu bricoler pour enregistrer tout ça. Vous allez voir qu'il y a eu quelques
couacs. Vous remarquerez notamment qu'il y a eu pas mal de réverbe chez tout le monde et aussi que le micro d'Allison a lâché après environ une heure d'interview.
Voilà, c'est toujours comme ça, on fait avec. Bonne écoute. Salut tout le monde. Aujourd'hui, on se retrouve pour un épisode très spécial sur un sujet exceptionnel : les troubles du comportement alimentaire.
Et pour ce faire, j'ai non pas un, mais deux invités d'exception. À commencer par le docteur Yves Simon. Bonjour docteur.
Bonjour. Vous êtes donc docteur psychiatre spécialisé dans le traitement des troubles du comportement alimentaire, leur détection et leur traitement.
Et nous sommes également rejoints par Allison. Salut Allison.
Salut.
Allison, tu es influenceuse, présente sur YouTube et Instagram et tu vis à Nancy.
On va explorer ensemble, comme je le disais, la question des troubles du comportement alimentaire, ce que ça signifie, comment ça se présente et toutes les questions sociétales qui sont liées à ce sujet.
Avant de se plonger au cœur de, de ce sujet-là, Allison, est-ce que je peux te demander,
déjà, je ne l'ai pas précisé, mais donc tu es avec nous parce que tu as connu et tu connais encore, on va en parler, des troubles, voilà, liés à la conduite alimentaire.
Est-ce que tu peux nous raconter comment ça s'est présenté chez toi, à quel âge c'est apparu et voilà, ton parcours un petit peu, donc lié aux troubles du comportement alimentaire ?
Oui, bien sûr. Alors moi, c'est apparu durant mon adolescence, quand j'avais une quinzaine d'années, même si je me souviens que bien avant ça, j'ai toujours eu, comment, un souci avec la perception de mon corps.
Et ça, ça remonte à mon enfance, je pense. Et ça s'est, du coup, ça s'est manifesté, oui, je devais être au tout début du lycée, par des vomissements, tout simplement, mais pas réellement des crises.
C'est-à-dire que parfois, j'estimais que je mangeais un peu trop, je me faisais vomir. Et au début, c'était très espacé.
Et puis, en fait, au fur et à mesure des années et surtout quand j'ai commencé à vivre seule, en fait, et à ne plus vivre chez mes parents, c'est là que les crises se sont beaucoup plus installées.
Et j'ai eu des périodes où je mangeais très, très peu, où j'alternais, en fait, des crises et des périodes de privation.
Ça s'est amélioré ensuite vers mes, je sais plus, peut-être vingt-sept ans, quelque chose comme ça.
Ok, donc une longue période quand même.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, plutôt— ah oui, complètement. Ben, ça m'a un petit peu façonnée. J'aime pas le dire, mais malgré tout, c'est vrai sur bien des domaines et je dirais que depuis quelques mois, c'est revenu.
Alors plus, vraiment, je fais plus de crises de boulimie, ça ne m'arrive plus, mais perpétuellement, la nourriture est dans ma tête.
Je dois manger, je ne dois pas manger. Est-ce que je peux manger ça ? Est-ce que j'ai le droit de me nourrir ? Et c'est plus ça, en fait, aujourd'hui, qui est très anxiogène.
Je me mets pas en danger, ça se voit, je suis pas, je suis pas maigre, mais c'est vrai que c'est vraiment cette charge mentale, en fait, qui est très, qui est très lourde.
Mh. Et donc, est-ce que tu peux nous parler de comment, comment ça a été reçu autour de toi ? Comment, par exemple, ça a été perçu par, par tes parents, par ta famille, par tes proches ?
Est-ce que tu estimes que ça a été une violence, vis-à-vis de, par— comment est-ce que ça s'est passé ?
Alors, de mon côté, c'est quelque chose, et je pense que c'est le cas de beaucoup de personnes qui souffrent de ça, que j'ai beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup caché.
C'est-à-dire que j'en ai parlé publiquement sur les réseaux sociaux en 2017, mais avant ça, j'ai dû le mentionner une première fois à des amis, peut-être en 2015.
Mon copain de l'époque, qui était au courant parce qu'il me voyait faire, donc lui, a été un des premiers, en fait, à voir qu'il y avait un souci, tout simplement en, en vivant avec moi.
Mais ma famille, c'est un sujet que j'ai amené, je pourrais plus dire. Bizarrement, parce que ça a dû être quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup travaillé et je pense que la première fois que j'en ai parlé avec eux, ça a dû me marquer,
mais en fait, je sais pas, j'ai oublié, je pense.
Je, je pense que mon cerveau a peut-être un peu fait exprès et je ne sais plus, la première fois que je leur en ai parlé, comment j'ai amené la chose.
Mais c'est vrai que ça n'a pas été— j'ai eu du mal à en parler, mais ça a été bien reçu, entre guillemets, par tout le monde.
J'ai pas— c'était ma crainte, ma crainte première, en fait. C'est aussi pour ça que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à même en parler de façon publique, parce que j'avais pas envie d'être associée à ça.
Et j'avais peur qu'on se moque, en fait, en me disant : « Mais t'es grosse, vomis encore. » Enfin, des choses horribles.
Mais c'est vrai que moi, comme je me suis toujours perçue— Enfin, j'ai, j'ai, je me suis toujours vue grosse, vraiment très grosse alors que non.
Et surtout, les, finalement, les moments de ma vie où j'étais le plus mal par rapport à mon corps, mais j'étais tout sauf grosse.
Personne n'aurait pu dire que j'étais grosse. Mais dans ma tête, c'était le cas. Et donc parler de ces troubles-là, j'aurais eu peur qu'on me dise : Oui, bah, tu as raison, continue parce que tu es grosse.
C'est complètement— ça paraît irréel, un peu déconnecté de la réalité, mais c'est aussi la réalité des gens malades. Ils se voient pas réellement, on souffre souvent de dysmorphophobie et on se voit pas en fait comme on est réellement.
En ce qui concerne donc le trouble que tu as connu, quelle serait alors l'étiquette ? Donc, tu parlais de te percevoir grosse, donc on part plutôt sur une anorexie.
Qu'est-ce que ça a été ?
Non, pas, pas réellement parce que pour moi, l'anorexie, déjà, c'est des, c'est des personnes qui en général sont très très maigres.
Moi, j'ai jamais été très très maigre. J'ai été mince. Je sais pas si aujourd'hui, on peut me qualifier de mince. J'ai toujours, j'ai beaucoup de mal à parler de tout ça.
Mais je— Non, je me suis jamais définie comme anorexique. Boulimique, oui, mais après, en fait, souvent, et j'ai— bon
ça, c'est des recherches que j'ai pu faire, de ce qu'on a pu me dire et autres, parce que forcément, j'ai été suivie.
Mais une espèce d'état mixte dans le sens où c'est de l'anorexie boulimie. C'est-à-dire que je peux— j'ai souvent eu des TCA, j'ai parfois fait des crises, mais c'est vrai que les crises, en fait, sont toujours compensées.
Donc c'est la, la boulimie et non l'hyperphagie qu'on confond parfois. Et ça, c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui, enfin, m'énerve.
Non, mais si parfois j'entends des personnes se définir comme boulimiques, non, pour moi, ils sont hyperphages. C'est pas— enfin, selon moi, c'est pas la même chose.
Je dis pas que c'est moins ou enfin que c'est plus sérieux, moins sérieux. Non, c'est tous les deux très chiant et horrible, mais c'est quand même assez différent.
Et moi, je sais que j'ai, j'ai vraiment alterné les, les deux phases qui finalement m'ont toujours fait, alors ça dépend des périodes, mais maintenir un poids plus ou moins normal, pas inquiétant du tout.
Et voilà, quand on me voit dans la rue, on se dit rien de particulier par rapport à mon physique.
Ça ne se voyait pas.
Voilà, exactement. Mais c'est vrai que c'est le problème de la boulimie, justement. À la, à la différence de l'anorexie où on voit la personne
beaucoup beaucoup maigrir et elle se dé— elle est décharnée, enfin, on voit qu'il y a, il y a un souci.
Là, la boulimie, non, la plupart du temps, on a un poids normal et c'est justement par nos, nos comportements compensatoires qu'on, qu'on arrive à garder un poids plus ou moins stable.
Même si en général, de ce que je peux remarquer autour de moi, souvent, les malades voguent, voguent pardon d'un état à un autre.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des personnes qui sont anorexiques, qui se finissent boulimiques et souvent, c'est un peu un mélange de tout.
Et moi, aujourd'hui, par exemple, je ne me définirais plus comme boulimique parce que je ne fais pas de crise.
Cependant, oui, j'ai quand même des TCA parce que ce n'est pas normal de se lever le matin et de se dire : Bon, est-ce que je peux manger aujourd'hui ?
Non, une personne normalement constituée ne se pose pas ces questions-là. Et il y a souvent en fait ce truc de : Est-ce que j'ai le droit de manger ?
Se donner l'autorisation. Alors que manger est quelque chose de vital. On se dit pas le matin : Est-ce que je peux respirer aujourd'hui ?
Non, ça paraît incongru. Bon ben là, ça devrait être la même chose. Donc c'est en ça que je me définis comme toujours un peu malade,
mais c'est pas non plus ce que j'ai pu connaître il y a des années où manger devant quelqu'un, par exemple, ça m'était impossible parce que j'avais peur du jugement.
Alors qu'encore une fois, il y avait pas de problème, mais c'était quelque chose pour moi de, de très compliqué. Et malgré tout, aujourd'hui,
même si c'est toujours— j'ai toujours des craintes par rapport à mon poids, je vois bien que les autres me perçoivent à peu près normalement et que je suis normale.
Mais il y a encore un peu ce truc-là d'un côté.
Ouais, ouais. Alors, on va revenir donc sur ton parcours et ce que tu disais sur le fait que tu as été un peu encadrée, suivie.
Donc, on va explorer ça dans un instant. Mais juste avant, avant, avant ça, je voulais demander, donc on a parlé de plusieurs définitions, plusieurs étiquettes : hyperphagie, boulimie, anorexie.
Et comme quoi, ça, certaines personnes pouvaient employer le terme, les termes d'hyperphagie et de boulimie de manière un peu confuse, mélanger un peu tout ça.
Donc, j'ai envie de vous demander, docteur, les définitions, en fait, respectivement d'hyperphagie, de boulimie et d'anorexie.
On a trouvé que c'était une très belle synthèse de ce qu'on peut rencontrer dans les troubles alimentaires. Alors, le terme d'étiquette, c'est important parce que ça peut être effectivement vécu comme stigmatisant ou un préjugé,
mais le terme anorexie mentale dans le langage médical, c'est associé à une définition, effectivement.
Hein, donc anorexie mentale, ça se caractérise par un poids bas. Il faut encore entendre, encore s'entendre sur ce qu'on entend un poids bas.
C'est généralement un indice de masse corporelle qui est divisé le poids par la taille carrée. S'il est inférieur à dix-huit,
effectivement, c'est un critère de diagnostic pour l'anorexie mentale, mais il doit être associé à d'autres caractéristiques et notamment ces préoccupations pour le poids, pour la silhouette, le sentiment d'être gros ou se voir gros.
Donc ça, ce sont de, de caractéristiques importantes.
Nous reviendrons peut-être tout à l'heure sur le fait qu'il existe aussi une autre forme de trouble alimentaire qu'on appelle
l'ARFID en anglais, c'est-à-dire l'évitement et la restriction de, de la prise alimentaire, que l'on rencontre chez les personnes qui n'ont pas de préoccupations corporelles.
Mais pour en revenir à l'anorexie mentale, dès le moment où il y a un diagnostic, c'est important pour le médecin parce que derrière, il y a un traitement.
Mais on ne fait pas seulement un diagnostic
sur la base du comportement alimentaire. Il y a deux grandes catégories de troubles alimentaires, comme ça a été souligné,
ceux qui sont dans la restriction et donc qui conduisent à un poids bas et ceux qui sont dans la perte de contrôle
de la prise alimentaire qu'on appelle accès hyperphagique et boulimique quand ces accès hyperphagiques sont associés à des comportements de, de
vomissements, d'utilisation de laxatifs ou d'exercices physiques excessifs.
Quelle distinction alors entre une patiente qui serait boulimique et une personne qui serait hyperphagique ? Quelle est la distinction ?
L'hyperphagie, c'est une personne qui présente uniquement des accès de perte de contrôle durant lesquels— de la prise alimentaire, durant lesquels elle mange de grandes quantités d'aliments.
Alors parfois, cette, cette sensation de perte de contrôle est subjective, c'est-à-dire que de l'extérieur, on n'a pas l'impression que la personne, ou en tout cas dans ce qu'elle rapporte,
qu'elle mange énormément, mais elle a quand même ce sentiment d'avoir transgressé des règles qu'elle s'était imposées au niveau de la quantité d'aliments qu'elle, qu'elle mange.
Et, et puis la boulimie, c'est quand ces accès hyperpha— en tout cas dans, dans la définition médicale, quand, quand ils sont associés à des stratégies qu'on appelle de, de, de compensatoires pour éviter de prendre du poids comme
les vomissements, l'utilisation de laxatifs ou l'exercice physique excessif,
alors on parle de boulimie.
Mais l'anorexie peut être une personne qui présente de l'anorexie peut être aussi présenter des accès hyperphagiques, des comportements compensatoires.
Et donc effectivement, c'est, c'est, c'est une affection qui peut être associée à ces, à ces comportements de perte de contrôle et qui peuvent aussi évoluer au cours du temps.
C'est ça.
Et passer d'un registre à l'autre.
Voilà, et donc ça rejoint ce que, ce qu'Allison dit en fait.
Tout à fait. Je disais que c'était une belle synthèse de ce que pouvaient être les troubles alimentaires.
Plus proche donc de l'anorexie et d'autres passages plus proches de la boulimie. Très intéressant. Donc Allison, oui, comme je le disais, comme tu le disais, donc tu as pu être encadrée et suivie.
Comment est-ce que ça s'est passé ? Est-ce que tu as eu toi-même un déclic de te dire : Mais j'ai besoin d'aide ? Ou comment est-ce que ça s'est passé ?
Alors oui, complètement. Il y a eu un déclic qui remonte à octobre 2016. J'ai très vite compris que j'avais des soucis, oui, avec la nourriture.
À partir du moment où je me suis fait vomir une première fois. Et d'ailleurs, je me souviens qu'une des premières fois où j'ai dû me faire vomir, ça devait être, ouais, je devais être en seconde ou au tout début de ma seconde,
mais c'était la toute première.
Donc seconde en France, ça correspond à...
Quinze, seize ans.
Quinze ans ? C'est ça.
C'est ça. Quinze, seize ans. Mais je me souviens, et c'est là qu'il y a un problème, je me souviens qu'au collège, donc collège, ça va de onze à quatorze,
une fois, je me souviens très très bien de ce moment, j'étais en voyage scolaire, j'ai mangé un kebab en Allemagne et je m'étais dit
: Mais ça serait tellement bien si j'arrivais à me faire vomir après mes repas parce que je pourrais manger ce que j'aime.
J'avais treize ans, donc c'est chaud quand même.
Et je voyais ça comme un goal quoi, comme un but et j'étais... Bon, voilà, avec le recul, je me dis ok, il y avait déjà un problème à la base, mais c'est vrai que oui, j'ai eu un déclic en fait lors d'un voyage.
J'ai vécu à Montréal, j'ai fait mes études à Montréal et en 2016, 2015-2016, ça a été des années très compliquées parce que je me suis réinstallée en France et j'ai emménagé seule.
Donc ça a été la dégringolade parce que qui— enfin, vivre seule, j'ai pu faire ce que je voulais au niveau de la nourriture, il n'y avait aucun contrôle extérieur.
Et je sais que ça n'allait pas très bien fin d'année 2016, donc je suis repartie à Montréal une semaine, histoire de me ressourcer.
Et j'ai passé la semaine en fait avec une amie,
une personne que j'estimais beaucoup, qui, elle, avait vu un psy pour un problème tout à fait différent et qui m'avait dit : Mais en fait, si là, Allison, il y a un problème, il n'y a pas de honte à aller voir un psy, ce n'est pas pour les fous.
Et c'est vrai qu'on a facilement, alors de moins en moins maintenant, je vois déjà une différence entre 2016 et 2022, par exemple.
Aujourd'hui, la santé mentale, on en parle beaucoup plus, mais sur des années en arrière ou même des générations précédentes, ce n'était pas forcément le premier réflexe.
Il y avait la santé physique, le mental, on s'en fichait un petit peu. Et moi, à ce moment-là, donc cette amie m'a plus ou moins convaincue.
Et je sais que quand je suis rentrée à Nancy la semaine qui a suivi, j'ai pris un premier rendez-vous avec un psychologue.
Puis après, j'ai vu une psychiatre aussi pendant un certain temps, pardon. J'ai arrêté et j'ai repris, j'ai repris dernièrement, même si là, ça fait un petit mois que j'y suis pas allée, que j'ai pas envie d'y aller.
Mais je suis honnête. Non, mais je suis honnête. Et ma psy, en plus, je l'ai croisée, j'étais à un concert et je l'ai croisée, je l'ai regardée, elle m'a regardée, on s'est souri.
Mais c'est vrai que faut pas se forcer, je pense. Alors c'est très— pour moi, c'est très important. En fait, la première étape, c'est d'en parler.
Pas forcément à un psy, pas forcément à des amis, à un parent, quelqu'un de confiance, quelqu'un qui saura recevoir la nouvelle parce que tout le monde n'a pas la même sensibilité par rapport à ça.
Donc c'est très important de choisir une personne de confiance et en qui on a confiance, tout simplement. Et l'étape suivante, oui, c'est de se faire encadrer
avec un professionnel, bien sûr, mais je pense qu'il y a des moments dans notre vie où ça sert à rien d'y aller parce que si on n'a pas envie de parler, si on ne veut pas parler, ça peut être un peu compliqué.
Mais c'est aussi une étape qui est très très très très très importante, ça soulage. Mais je pars du principe qu'à partir du moment où la souffrance devient extrême, moi, je sais que
j'ai été réticente, mais en fait, à un moment, j'en ai tellement souffert que je me suis dit : Mais c'est pas possible, en fait.
Là, sinon, je vois pas, je vois pas de solution, il faut que j'y aille. Et c'est comme ça que j'y suis allée par une amie donc qui m'a, qui m'a convaincue, qui m'en a parlé.
Et voilà, pour moi, c'était une personne équilibrée. C'est— enfin, je veux pas mal parler, mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque, j'avais une image quand même assez négative de la thérapie.
Et quand j'ai vu cette personne, voilà, cette amie qui finalement avait vu un psy et ça l'avait beaucoup aidée, je me suis dit que ça pourrait être une bonne solution.
Donc, tu parles de trouver quelqu'un avec qui c'est possible, facile de, de, de partager ces choses-là. Et tu parlais du fait que tu l'avais beaucoup beaucoup caché en grandissant vis-à-vis de ta famille, etc.
Du coup, j'ai envie de te demander qu'est-ce qui fait que spontanément, c'est quelque chose dont on ressent le besoin de le cacher, d'en avoir honte, de ne pas en parler ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut pas simplement exprimer, partager avec sa famille, avec ses amis le fait qu'on a un problème vis-à-vis de l'image de soi, de son corps, de son alimentation ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on ressent le besoin de ne pas en parler, en fait ?
Alors, c'est drôle comme question parce que moi, quand je l'entends, elle me paraît— c'est évident. Pour moi, c'est honteux et c'est
aujourd'hui quelque chose que j'assume beaucoup plus et dont je parle facilement, même si ce n'est pas forcément la première chose que j'ai envie de dire quand je parle de moi.
Mais dans le fait, en tout cas, je sais que dans la boulimie, moi, ce qui me faisait honte, c'est le vomissement. C'est dégueulasse de vomir, vous voyez ?
Et c'est surtout ce truc-là. Et je sais qu'au-delà de ça, c'est que j'ai toujours été, même si c'est très paradoxal parce que je fais un métier d'image et parfois, les gens ont du mal à comprendre qu'on peut être extrêmement complexé.
C'est là où tu vois— parce que je me montre et pour autant, j'ai parfois du mal avec mon image. Donc c'est un grand paradoxe.
Mais je sais que de mon côté, comme j'ai souvent eu un problème avec mon image, au-delà de mon image, ce n'est pas tant que je me trouve moche, c'est que je me trouve grosse.
Ce n'est pas pareil, mais je préférais toujours dire que j'ai un problème avec mon— j'aime pas en fait pointer le poids parce que j'aurais peut-être, je pense, en le disant, trop peur qu'on me dise : Ouais, t'as raison, t'es grosse.
Et ça, ça serait sûrement la pire chose. Mais encore une fois, on en revient à un autre problème, c'est que
On ne devrait pas— j'ai, j'ai une obsession pour le poids et le corps d'une façon générale, mais qui, qui est pas, qui est pas normale parce qu'on n'est pas défini par notre poids.
Moi, c'est très certainement, je pense, des choses peut-être que j'ai— enfin pas peut-être, des choses qui sont liées à mon enfance, que j'ai enregistrées.
Et à trente ans, j'ai toujours du mal à m'en défaire, mais quelque part, ma valeur, je la définis par mon poids alors que ça n'a aucun rapport.
Mais au-delà de ça, je vois le poids comme une condition sine qua non au bonheur. C'est-à-dire, et ça, je le pense toujours et je pense pas être la seule fille ou le seul,
comment, le seul garçon, mais je pense que c'est quand même quelque chose qui, on y reviendra peut-être, mais qui touche plus facilement les filles.
Mais combien de fois j'ai pu me dire : Non, mais je ferai ça quand j'aurai trois kilos de moins. Alors que l'action en question n'a aucun rapport avec mon corps, mais je me sens plus légitime, je me sens mieux quand je suis plus mince.
Et donc tu parlais de choses peut-être liées à ton enfance. Donc j'avais envie de te demander, si c'est pas trop intrusif, évidemment, si t'es à l'aise pour en parler.
Mais en fait, les causes, d'où est-ce que c'est venu, ce sentiment d'associer donc ta valeur, comme tu disais, à ton poids, à ton tour de taille ?
Alors, je pense que ça vient de remarques que j'ai pu entendre, qui m'ont, qui comme ça en fait peut-être avaient l'air de rien.
Et ça encore une fois, c'est, bon, c'est notre perception à chacun parce qu'on n'est pas forcément, on n'est pas responsable de ce que les autres comprennent et comment ils le comprennent.
On est responsable de ce qu'on dit, mais après, c'est vrai que chacun fait bien ce qu'il veut. Mais je pense que moi, oui, ça vient de phrases que j'ai pu entendre et qui m'ont un peu matrixée.
Et parfois des phrases qu'on a pu me dire, je sais pas, j'avais sept ans, mais pourtant, c'est des phrases auxquelles je pense toujours à trente.
Et c'est vrai que c'est là où je pense, avec les jeunes enfants, il faut faire extrêmement attention.
Je pense que les générations actuelles, et c'est quelque chose que je remarque
plus facilement sur les femmes de cinquante ans et plus, elles ont quand même plus facilement un rapport, alors, je trouve en tout cas quand elles parlent, et je vois ça avec les mères de mes copains ou des choses comme ça, elles ont,
elles ont quand même un peu aussi ce souci de : une femme doit être mince.
Il y a pas autre chose qui est recevable. Une femme doit être mince. Par contre, l'homme, c'est moins important. En tout cas, c'est ce que je comprends.
Et je sais que ces remarques-là, voilà, certaines remarques que j'ai pu entendre. Et après, au-delà de ça, une prise de poids.
En fait, étant petite, j'étais extrêmement maigre. Enfin maigre, on me le faisait remarquer et on le disait même à mes parents : Elle est maigre, vous la nourrissez.
Oui, oui, c'est juste que j'étais très fine. Et on a eu un souci de famille, une période un peu compliquée et en un an, j'ai grossi.
Et je me rappelle, mais j'en ai encore,
j'en ai encore peur, je vois encore ma courbe de poids, mais elle m'a traumatisée, avec les pédiatres où on m'a engueulée parce que j'ai grossi, on m'a privée, c'est-à-dire que je-- et ça, c'est un souvenir très marquant.
Je devais avoir neuf ans, j'allais à un goûter d'anniversaire, moi, j'ai pas le droit de manger de gâteau. J'étais pas obèse hein,
mais j'avais pas le droit de manger de gâteau, j'avais pris du poids et je me souviens avoir demandé à ma mère : Maman, je peux manger du gâteau ?
Un enfant de neuf ans ne devrait pas poser cette question. Et en fait, c'est plein de choses comme ça qui m'ont,
qui m'ont un peu, qui m'ont abîmée et qui ont fait qu'à l'âge adulte, quand bien même peu importe le poids que j'ai pu faire, j'ai toujours eu un problème avec mon corps et je me suis toujours dit : Bah, t'es trop grosse.
Mais je me souviens plus des questions de base.
Non, non, mais t'as très bien répondu.
Ok.
Je vais maintenant me retourner donc vers le docteur Simon. Donc on a entendu ici le profil donc d'Allison, qui est donc très fort lié à l'image de soi, à ce qu'elle a le droit de faire, à des questions donc de culpabilisation.
C'est peut-être intéressant hein de la part donc de la famille, mais aussi des pédiatres et toutes ces choses-là.
Donc ça, c'est un profil, le profil d'Allison. Est-ce que, dans les patients, les patientes que vous avez pu recevoir, vous entendez d'autres profils qui reviennent souvent,
vis-à-vis des causes, vis-à-vis de ce qui peut donc entraîner donc un-
Alors, l'histoire qui est racontée ici est un peu paradigmatique hein. C'est très clair. Qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve ?
Ce sont des préoccupations, parfois dès l'enfance, hein, concernant le poids, la silhouette, des remarques. Mais ça peut-- les remarques, ça peut être des lunettes, ça peut être un acné, ça peut être d'autres éléments que simplement le poids.
Mais à notre époque, c'est souvent effectivement le poids, l'encouragement pour une jeune fille qui, au moment de la puberté, prend du poids, quelques remarques : Mais tu dois faire attention à ton poids.
Attention, il faut pas que tu deviennes grosse. Alors que ce qui se passe à ce moment-là, c'est un développement physiologique qui est tout à fait normal.
Certaines personnes grandissent avant de prendre de la morphologie et d'autres prennent de la morphologie avant de prendre de la taille.
Donc, il y a des petites différences, mais au niveau de l'histoire, c'est pour moi tout à fait paradigmatique. Et ce qui,
je pense, on a insisté, peut-être quelques petites informations complémentaires. Quand on essaye de comprendre comment commence cette affection, en général, c'est pas que la personne se dit
: Je fais quelque chose d'étrange.
Non, c'est un peu comme si c'était légitime dans un contexte dans lequel on est, contrôler son poids, son apparence, c'est tout à fait légitime.
Et cela est renforcé par des remarques qui touchent naturellement la confiance en soi et l'estime de soi. Et généralement, on considère qu'il faut de neuf à seize mois pour que des parents s'aperçoivent qu'il y a un problème chez leur fille.
Et c'est vrai que c'est peut-être pas tenu secret, c'est peut-être secret. C'est vrai qu'il faut pouvoir en parler.
Naturellement, plus elles en parlent tôt à leurs parents, mieux c'est. Mais en fort, faut-il qu'elles aient la possibilité de communiquer ce qu'elles sont en train de vivre.
Ce que je voudrais aussi souligner, c'est que dès le moment où ces personnes commencent à perdre du poids ou à restreindre leur alimentation, ce qui inquiète l'entourage,
elles peuvent recevoir des encouragements pour manger normalement.
Et donc à ce moment-là, elles se retrouvent dans une situation où elles peuvent souffrir d'un grand sentiment de solitude parce qu'on leur demande de faire l'inverse de ce qui leur permet de se sentir bien. Mmh.
Ce qui permet de sentir bien, c'est de faire régime et on les encourage à manger, à manger. Donc il y a une incompréhension qui s'installe, un sentiment de solitude
qui peut être extrêmement profond chez une personne qui-- chez un jeune comme ça, qui développe ce type de stratégie alimentaire.
Et donc lorsqu'on les reçoit en consultation, la première chose à faire, outre l'anamnèse, et ne pas simplement se focaliser sur les critères de diagnostic que je viens
d'évoquer, mais de regarder de manière plus large quelle est la qualité de vie.
Vous venez d'évoquer que,
ben il y avait peut-être des moments un peu difficiles dans la vie, il y avait ces remarques, il y avait des moments peut-être difficiles dans la vie familiale, donc des situations de
stress, mais des situations de stress qui ne sont pas spécifiques
en tout cas aux troubles alimentaires, qui sont des événements de vie qui sont stressants,
mais qui n'ont aucun caractère répréhensible.
Ou enfin, je ne sais pas. Naturellement, il y a des situations, oui, mais pas nécessairement des événements qui semblent tout à fait traumatiques, je dirais.
Mais parfois, malheureusement, ça existe aussi. Donc voilà, il faut élargir l'évaluation et la première chose qui est à faire, c'est de donner à la personne la compréhension de ce qui s'est passé.
Et ça, c'est très important de donner une compréhension, que la personne comprenne un petit peu dans quoi elle est engagée et quelle est notre compréhension à la fois physiologique et psychologique du processus.
Mmh.
Mmh. Parce que les accès hyperphagiques ou les boulimies, c'est une conséquence de la dénutrition. Mais mieux encore que la dénutrition, des règles que la personne se fixe dans sa tête.
Elle se fixe des règles, elle n'arrive pas à les respecter et donc à ce moment-là, elle se met en restriction alimentaire ou en attention alimentaire plus importante.
Et ça, c'est la raison du craquage et de l'accès hyperphagique. Et donc quand on veut engager un traitement, la première chose à faire, c'est d'aider la personne à arrêter les vomissements et à mettre en place une structure alimentaire.
Mais la première chose à faire, c'est de lui donner une compréhension de son problème sur la base des informations qui sont données.
Par exemple, ce qui vient d'être dit ici est tout à fait paradigmatique et on a des modèles qui sont très clairs et qui permettent de donner une compréhension de ce qui s'est passé.
Voilà. Donc ça rejoint donc l'expérience, le profil que-
Oui
... qu'Allison a présenté. Si maintenant on s'intéresse à d'autres profils, j'ai par exemple pu entendre parler de profils où la restriction alimentaire était plutôt là pour
finalement une forme d'automutilation ou une forme de contrôle, de haine de soi-même.
Et donc l'anorexie, elle est plutôt là alors pour se faire souffrir. Est-ce que vous avez pu rencontrer des-
Oui, on rencontre naturellement des situations, mais elles sont plus rares.
Plus rares, OK.
C'est-à-dire qu'elles sont plus rares. Des conduites destructives, c'est, ça vient parfois avec le temps, mais au départ, pas vraiment.
Il n'y a pas d'intention de se détruire. Il y a le sentiment d'avoir un comportement qui est légitime.
Mmh.
Mais alors, ce qui a, comme je l'ai souligné tout à l'heure, il faut regarder aussi est-ce qu'il y a une symptomatologie anxieuse, de la dépression ?
On montre maintenant, on insiste beaucoup que trente pour cent de ces patientes ont aussi des traits
de caractère qu'on appelle du spectre de l'autisme, hein, c'est-à-dire une difficulté dans les relations interpersonnelles, une certaine rigidité dans la manière de penser,
et aussi des sensibilités sensorielles, notamment gustatives, particulières.
On parle de trente pour cent ?
Trente pour cent. Mais attention, hein, un profil autistique, ce sont certaines caractéristiques. Parfois, c'est plus profond, parfois c'est moins profond.
Et l'autisme n'est pas considéré comme une maladie, mais comme une manière-- c'est un développement cérébral qui conduit à avoir-
Une différence
...des traits de caractère particuliers et on peut les retrouver chez trente pour cent. Et donc c'est important de repérer, c'est ce qu'on appelle en quelque sorte des comorbidités ou des troubles associés,
pour ne pas simplement se focaliser sur les préoccupations corporelles et sur le comportement alimentaire.
Il faut aussi élargir l'évaluation. Et notamment l'évaluation, c'est aussi la situation de vie.
Donc c'est là qu'on voit vraiment qu'il y a,
ben, donc un spectre de l'autisme, mais aussi un spectre des troubles du comportement alimentaire, puisqu'on peut arriver
à la restriction alimentaire pour des questions d'image de soi, pour des questions de ce qu'on a le droit de faire, de comment est-ce qu'on doit être, etc.,
donc les constructions qu'Allison a présentées.
Mais on peut aussi y arriver donc via le chemin de l'autisme et via donc des questions de-- Ben, oui, quel est, quel sera alors le chemin entre une personne qui serait autiste jusqu'à l'anorexie ?
Alors la personne est-- il y a des traits. Alors parfois, elle l'est, mais il y a des traits. Ce qu'il y a, c'est que les personnes consultent parfois vingt ans plus tard,
parce qu'elles s'aperçoivent que leur manière de s'alimenter, effectivement, n'était pas habituelle.
Mais souvent, quand c'est associé à une perte de poids, ce sont des jeunes qui consultent avec leurs parents, qui sont un peu inquiets du fait que l'enfant ou le jeune adolescent ne mange pas suffisamment.
Mais c'est généralement pas parce qu'il ne mange pas suffisamment, mais parce qu'il a des goûts alimentaires très particuliers.
C'est ça. Donc des restrictions vis-à-vis donc des questions alors sensorielles ?
Il y a des espaces sensorielles. Alors, ce qui est-- alors parfois dans les émissions, on nous dit : mangez cinq fruits et cinq légumes.
Mmh-mmh.
Or justement, ces personnes qui ont ces caractéristiques, elles ont un répertoire alimentaire assez restreint, ou bien elles ne mangent que des aliments auxquels elles sont habituées.
Mmh-mmh. OK, donc vraiment encore une fois, toute une série de profils différents qui sont possibles.
Alors il y a des profils différents.
J'ai pas posé la question en fait, les personnes donc concernées par les troubles du comportement alimentaire, on parle de quel pourcentage ?
À quel point est-ce que c'est fréquent ?
Trois à huit pour cent.
Trois à huit pour cent ?
Des personnes que, que-- connaissent-
Adolescentes, oui, et qui ont des formes subcliniques jusqu'à actuellement dix-sept pour cent.
Donc il y a la question alors de si c'est trois à huit pour cent. Sont diagnostiqués. Est-ce que ?
Non, ce sont dans des études épidémiologiques sur la base de questionnaires ou bien d'interviews pour évaluer des fréquences de maladies.
Bah, on sélectionne une population, les femmes entre douze et seize ans, et puis on va en interroger un échantillon. Et puis de ces échantillons, des résultats, on en tire des conclusions.
Une personne peut avoir un diagnostic d'anorexie mentale sans avoir été détectée et avoir traversé toute sa vie ou de nombreuses années avec un trouble alimentaire sans qu'il ait jamais été détecté.
Et donc, ce qui a naturellement beaucoup biaisé les recherches qui étaient faites il y a cinquante ans, hein, c'est que les personnes n'étaient pas du tout détectées dans les études épidémiologiques.
C'est fascinant. On a parlé tout à l'heure de la question donc du genre et du fait que c'était principalement les femmes qui étaient concernées.
Allison, tu es une femme. À ton avis, qu'est-ce qui explique cette disparité, cette différence ? Pourquoi est-ce que c'est principalement les femmes qui sont concernées ?
Je pense qu'on est plus facilement concerné dû au fait que je pense la société, alors c'est peut-être de moins en moins, de moins en moins, pardon, mais ça l'est toujours quand même un petit peu.
La société pose un jugement et un regard beaucoup plus lourd sur nos corps de femmes que sur celui des hommes. Et ça, je trouve que c'est quelque chose que l'on retrouve dans l'éducation.
J'ai déjà entendu ma grand-mère ou ma mère faire des réflexions sur le poids, le corps d'une femme, rarement sur celui d'un homme qui a un ventre, par exemple.
Donc, je pense que dès notre naissance, et ça, c'est même plein de fois, j'ai pu le remarquer
dans des dîners de famille, pas forcément ma famille, mais avec des amis ou autres, la femme est toujours plus jugée sur son physique et notamment son poids que l'homme.
J'ai déjà entendu des remarques comme ça qui moi, me choquent, mais non, c'est normal de lui dire qu'elle a grossi, qu'il faut qu'elle fasse attention, qu'elle a plus le corps de ses vingt ans.
Ben oui, mais elle en a soixante, donc c'est normal. Par contre, monsieur a pris de la bidoche, ça, c'est pas grave. Je rigole, mais c'est des remarques qui, moi, peuvent me choquer, en tout cas.
Et donc, je pense que ça vient de là. Même si je pense que j'ai déjà rencontré des garçons avec des TCA, mais je pense que la société, ouais, est quand même plus, porte un jugement plus lourd sur le corps des femmes.
Donc ça vient de là, puisqu'en général, ça s'inscrit durant l'enfance, l'adolescence.
Quand tu parles
du fait que tu as rencontré des hommes avec des TCA, est-ce que ce sont alors des personnes qui ont été diagnostiquées ou alors est-ce que ce sont des personnes où tu te rends compte en discutant avec eux qu'il y a peut-être un problème ?
Alors, en général, je m'en rends compte très vite parce que je vois qu'ils peuvent me ressembler sur certains points où quand on se connaît, quand on sait ce qu'on a,
juste un dîner, mais juste, ça, c'est quelques petites remarques ou une façon de manger, on peut voir qu'il y a un problème.
Et puis, si on creuse un peu et qu'on parle avec la personne, moi, je sais que voilà, quand je me reconnais en eux, bon ben, je sais qu'il y a deux, trois trucs qui sont pas très, très clairs de ce côté-là.
Après, les quelques personnes auxquelles je pense, je sais pas s'ils ont été suivis. Je pense que ça aurait été bon à un moment.
Mais diagnostiqués, ça, j'en suis pas sûre. Mais en tout cas, oui, je-- et puis eux-mêmes parfois le disent, ils s'en cachent pas parce que c'est quelque chose, ça, c'est une question qu'on m'avait déjà posée.
Je me souviens, j'avais vu une diététicienne il y a des années et à ce moment-là, 'fin, j'étais absolument pas en surpoids, mais je n'étais absolument pas grosse, mais moi, je voulais toujours peser moins.
Et j'avais été voir cette diététicienne très peu compétente et j'avais fait part du fait que, ben oui, je faisais des crises de boulimie.
Puis elle m'a dit : '' Mais comment vous savez que vous êtes boulimique ?'' Elle comprenait pas. Et je sais qu'il y a ce truc aussi de parfois de personnes qui--
Je pense que parfois, certains se définissent alors que
pas réellement, mais quand ça nous suit depuis des années et des années et des années et des années, qu'on se renseigne ou ben qu'on a été voir un spécialiste,
c'est quelque chose qui nous paraît assez évident et on le voit aussi sur les autres, juste parfois en parlant avec eux, en les observant.
D'accord, OK. Une réaction par rapport à ce qu'Allison vient de nous expliquer ?
Alors oui, donc on vient surtout parler de l'anorexie mentale. On n'a pas encore beaucoup parlé de la boulimie.
La boulimie, ou en tout cas les accès hyperphagiques, c'est généralement la conséquence de la restriction alimentaire,
mais aussi de ce qu'on appelle la restriction cognitive, c'est-à-dire que la personne se fixe des règles pour s'alimenter, hein, le contrôle.
Et comme elle déroge à ces règles à certains moments, parce que les mécanismes physiologiques de la faim, du rassasiement, de l'appétit, ben conduisent nécessairement à s'alimenter.
Quand le poids est trop bas, il y a des mécanismes depuis la nuit des temps, toutes les espèces animales, et l'espèce humaine est une espèce animale, met en place des mécanismes pour se protéger de la dénutrition.
Et donc, quand une personne se fixe des règles et a fortiori si elle perd du poids, il y a des mécanismes qui se mettent en place qui l'amènent à perdre le contrôle de son alimentation.
Alors, c'est ce qu'on voit très fréquemment hein, si nous ne mangeons pas au petit déjeuner à midi, on rentre chez soi à quatre heures et on commence à manger de manière excessive.
Il y a des mécanismes régulateurs qui augmentent à ce moment-là notre appétit et qui nous conduisent à manger plus. Et si on répète ce comportement, ben ça se désorganise
et à un moment donné, la personne ne mange plus sur la base de ses sensations de faim, de rassasiement ou d'appétit,
mais en fonction de ses croyances et de ses émotions.
Et alors souvent, on considère que les accès hyperphagiques, ce sont des accès qui sont liés à des états émotionnels.
En fait, la recherche montre très bien que ce qui fragilise au niveau émotionnel pour conduire à la crise, c'est la restriction alimentaire et c'est la restriction cognitive.
Et ça, c'est très, très important à expliquer parce que dès le moment où une personne restaure une alimentation structurée, elle peut voir fortement diminuer ses accès hyperphagiques.
Et donc, vis-à-vis des patients, vous êtes crédible. C'est-à-dire que même si c'est un effort que de remettre en place sa structure alimentaire, si ça donne un effet sur les accès hyperphagiques.
Et à mon avis, 'fin, c'est ce qu'on a montré aussi, c'est que les personnes qui présentent des accès boulimiques sont beaucoup plus dans la honte et dans la gêne et en parlent beaucoup moins facilement de ces accès hyperphagiques.
Mmh. Et ce sont des études qui ont été faites dans les années septante du siècle précédent, où on s'est aperçu que la boulimie était beaucoup plus fréquente que ce qu'on imaginait.
Parce que toute conduite de régime peut conduire à l'accès hyperphagique ou à la prise de poids.
Mmm hmm. OK. Et donc-
L'anorexie mentale, là, c'est une maladie un peu particulière, très complexe, qu'on comprend encore très mal. On a des éléments de compréhension,
alors que les accès hyperphagiques, on a une meilleure compréhension dès que c'est une conséquence de conduite de régime.
Quand-- Donc, vous parlez donc de conséquence, donc, d'un contrôle et du fait d'être dans des situations où on brise des règles.
Cette recherche de contrôle, est-ce que ça peut être ce que recherchent certains patients, certaines patientes ?
Ce qu'on recherche parce qu'on-- dans une situation où on n'est pas en contrôle dans le reste de sa vie.
Voilà.
Oui ?
Donc voilà, il y a différents facteurs que c'est intéressant d'identifier, de pouvoir les organiser. C'est que souvent, dans une situation de stress,
il y a un état de mal-être, il y a une situation qui est insatisfaisante et la personne trouve une manière, en quelque sorte, d'exercer un contrôle en contrôlant son alimentation.
Mais c'est vrai qu'on retrouve souvent une difficulté à vivre des situations sur lesquelles elle n'a pas de contrôle, que ce soit des relations interpersonnelles ou que ce soit des situations scolaires ou professionnelles ou autres.
C'est fascinant. Est-ce qu'on a quelque chose encore à ajouter vis-à-vis donc du fait que ce sont principalement des patientes, des femmes ?
Est-ce que, je sais pas, chez Allison ou chez vous, docteur ?
Oui, alors quelque chose chez les femmes, c'est qu'elles ont tendance, lorsqu'elles se présentent, à se critiquer, ce qui n'est pas le cas d'un homme.
Il faut les aider à être très attentives à cela. Et notamment,
quand on donne des recommandations aux mamans de jeunes qui sont dans un trouble alimentaire, on dit : Maman, faites attention, ne vous critiquez pas devant votre fille parce que ça, c'est pas quelque chose qui va l'aider.
Mmm hmm.
Voilà. Au papa, on donne d'autres recommandations, c'est de ne pas être critique à l'égard de leur fille, notamment sur le poids et sur les formes corporelles ou sur toute autre femme, naturellement.
Donc, on a parlé donc de construction sociale, du fait que la société, comme disait Allison, définissait donc le corps idéal d'une femme plutôt comme étant mince, lisse, ce qui n'est pas donc le cas pour les hommes.
On va plutôt attendre des hommes un corps avec du muscle, avec donc un corps plus imposant.
On voit de plus en plus d'hommes qui ont des troubles alimentaires hein.
Parce qu'ils se sentent plus libres à en parler ou parce qu'il y en a plus ?
Non, parce qu'ils portent beaucoup plus d'attention à leur apparence qu'auparavant.
D'accord, OK.
Oui.
Donc peut-être alors quelque chose qui serait lié à la présence des réseaux sociaux, qui va peut-être-
Voilà, les réseaux sociaux jouent certainement, enfin, jouent un rôle très important. On sait que, bon, ces jeunes filles vont souvent sur les réseaux sociaux et les jeunes hommes aussi.
Oui.
Mais on sait qu'ils sont beaucoup plus aidés par des relations réelles que par des relations sur les réseaux sociaux.
Mmm hmm.
Mais en même temps, les réseaux sociaux ont une fonction qui est à la fois importante parce que comme ils se reconnaissent dans les personnes qui sont sur les réseaux sociaux, ça diminue leur sentiment de solitude.
Alors ceux qui disent souvent : Tiens, cette jeune fille, elle est aidée dans les réseaux sociaux, on l'encourage.
Moi aussi, je voudrais être encouragé. Moi aussi, je voudrais être soutenu. Et là, ce qui est important, et ça, c'est un élément très très important, c'est là qu'il faut se tourner vers l'entourage et en particulier vers les parents.
Mmm.
Hein. Il faut toujours intégrer les parents dans les procédures thérapeutiques. Ça, c'est très très important. C'est vrai que la culture est importante, mais elle est surtout importante pour la boulimie et les accès hyperphagiques.
L'anorexie mentale, c'est beaucoup plus complexe.
Donc toujours, dans la question de la culture et de la société et de ce qui nous construit en tant qu'individu et donc qui peut nous amener à des troubles du comportement alimentaire.
La question de la classe, est-ce qu'il y a aussi-- est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi une question de
: être gros, c'est être dans une classe inférieure et les riches, les personnes privilégiées, sont plutôt dans une démarche où elles ont envie d'un corps idéal, d'un corps parfait, d'un corps.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas une notion, un facteur de la classe sociale aussi qui vient jouer ?
D'abord, un point important : la prévention de l'obésité et la prévention des troubles alimentaires, c'est la même prévention et doit être centrée sur l'estime de soi.
Ça ne va pas être une prévention médicalisée ou diététique. En ce qui concerne l'obésité,
l'obésité, effectivement, a augmenté de manière très importante ces cinquante dernières années et plutôt dans les classes sociales paupérisées que dans les classes sociales qui sont favorisées.
Ça, c'est vrai. Mais il y a des études qui montrent aussi qu'à calories égales, la calorie de graisse est moins chère que toute une autre calorie.
Tout à fait.
Et donc, ce sont des études très, très intéressantes qui ont été menées aux États-Unis, c'est que le choix alimentaire s'oriente aussi vers des aliments qui sont disponibles et peu coûteux.
Oui, c'est plus facile de se nourrir chez McDo que dans un repas qui serait bien sur le plan diététique.
C'est plus facile, c'est plus accessible, c'est moins cher.
Mais il y a aussi quelque chose qui est central dans l'obésité, c'est la génétique.
Mmm hmm.
On ne décide pas de son poids. C'est comme la taille, on ne décide pas de sa taille. On ne décide pas de son poids, si ce n'est que le poids, on a le sentiment qu'on peut le réguler, qu'on peut le contrôler.
Or, c'est faux. Dès le moment où on s'engage dans des conduites de régime, ce qui va se passer, c'est que soit on va présenter des accès hyperphagiques, soit on va faire des yo-yo et puis le poids va augmenter progressivement.
Les femmes qui suppriment le goûter de seize heures pour transférer la prise alimentaire au repas du soir prennent plus de poids dans les dix ans que les femmes qui maintiennent le goûter.
Donc la régularité des prises alimentaires est importante. Donc désorganiser les prises alimentaires, c'est quelque chose qui favorise l'obésité, qui favorise le surpoids, qui favorise l'accès hyperphagique.
L'anorexie mentale, ça, c'est encore quelque chose de très très particulier où là, on montre effectivement sur le plan immunologique, sur le plan métabolique et sur le plan
cérébral, des modifications quand même qui sont quand même très très claires.
D'accord. Donc quand vous dites : on ne décide pas de son poids, donc là, il y a vraiment, comme disait, le facteur génétique.
Le poids est régulé et s'il y a un poids qui, c'est comme un thermostat pour un radiateur, vous le mettez sur vingt-cinq, la température sera à vingt-cinq.
Des personnes auront un poids naturellement à un percentile, à un poids qui sera bas et d'autres personnes auront peu d'embonpoint, d'autres personnes sont dans l'obésité.
Et ce n'est pas un choix. Et la meilleure preuve, c'est que toutes les thérapies qui visent chez les personnes en surpoids à perdre du poids échouent après trois à cinq ans.
Alors, c'est peut-être une question un peu étrange, mais Allison, quand donc toi qui connais encore des
des troubles du comportement alimentaire, quand tu entends des phrases de type : On ne peut pas choisir son poids, le poids, il est comme ça, c'est tout.
Qu'est-ce que tu ressens intérieurement quand tu entends ça ?
Non, je ressens rien, mais ça me fait sourire parce que si on mange moins, on maigrit. Après, je suis d'accord hein, moi, toute ma vie, j'ai fait du yo-yo, et il y a encore pas très longtemps, j'avais quinze kilos de plus.
Mais c'est, oui, je me suis en fait accommodée de ça. Je me suis résignée quelque part. J'ai pas un cancer, ouais, j'ai pas un cancer en stade terminal.
J'arrive à vivre, à survivre. Survivre, c'est peut-être un peu dur comme mot, mais je m'en accommode. Mais oui, en soi, je suis d'accord.
C'est vrai qu'on n'a pas tous la même génétique, très clairement. Après, je pense qu'on peut quand même toujours... Alors, je sais pas.
Et ça, c'est peut-être mon côté mauvais qui parle, mais...
Mais voilà, justement oui.
L'alimentation, c'est aussi, il y a des gens, moi, je vois parfois des personnes autour de moi qui se plaignent d'être en surpoids.
Oui, mais enfin, tu manges quatre raclettes par semaine. À un moment, c'est peut-être aussi lié à notre façon aussi de nous alimenter.
Et moi, je sais que les périodes où j'ai grossi, bon bah c'est parce que je mangeais gras à tous les repas quoi. Et les périodes où je pèse moins lourd, bah parce que je mange beaucoup moins gras.
Le docteur a envie de réagir, je pense.
Oui, parce que ça, c'est à mon avis un des éléments qui ressort de la recherche. C'est un des facteurs les plus solides.
C'est-à-dire organiser son alimentation avec cinquante pour cent d'hydrates de carbone permet de stabiliser son poids.
Avec l'âge, on prend un peu du poids, mais il y a, alors pas chez tous, chez à peu près septante ou quatre-vingt pour cent des personnes.
La meilleure manière de ne pas prendre du poids, c'est de manger régulièrement, ne jamais laisser plus de trois à quatre heures entre deux repas et de faire de ces repas des repas qui, principalement ou cinquante pour cent, sont des féculents.
Ça, c'est très clair. Parce que si on mange, par exemple, si les personnes mangent des régimes hyperprotéinés, nous avons en fait un très fort contrôle inné sur les protéines.
Vous dites que la meilleure manière de garder un poids stable, c'est de manger régulièrement avec suffisamment de-
féculents.
Féculents, oui. Donc, on peut aussi faire les mauvaises décisions et faire le choix. Par exemple, je connais des gens qui m'ont expliqué qu'en fait, elles ne mangeaient jamais de féculents.
Elles ont supprimé les féculents de l'alimentation. On peut prendre cette décision et donc ça va avoir un impact a priori négatif sur le poids.
Et sur le comportement alimentaire.
Vous commenciez tout à l'heure en expliquant qu'on ne choisit pas son poids. Mais on peut prendre des mauvaises décisions vis-à-vis de son alimentation.
Donc on peut le choisir son poids.
Oui, mais c'est ce qu'il y a derrière, c'est le problème, c'est notamment à l'adolescence, quand une jeune fille ou un garçon commence à chercher à contrôler son poids, ce qu'il ne sait pas, c'est qu'il y a un piège derrière.
C'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné, il y a des mécanismes qui vont se mettre en place, qui vont le conduire à se réalimenter.
Et donc ça va lui faire peur. Il cherche à contrôler son poids, puis il déroge à ces règles qu'il s'est fixées. Il commence à manger des aliments gras et sucrés ou présenter des-- ou manger de manière excessive.
On rentre au goûter, on mange beaucoup. Donc il y a une peur qui s'installe. Et puis donc, il y a une alternance de perte de contrôle et de comportements restrictifs.
Et donc il y a un cercle vicieux. Donc, c'est le piège.
Autrement dit, les régimes, ça ne fonctionne pas.
Les régimes, ça ne fonctionne pas. Cinq à dix pour cent du poids, oui, mais pas plus.
OK oui, c'est ça. Donc, il y a une marge de fonctionnement.
Oui.
Allison, tu parlais d'avoir pris quinze kilos auparavant. Donc, on peut varier de manière marginale, mais pas de manière trop importante quoi.
Ou en tout cas, quand on veut rester...
Ça dépend des personnes. Il y a des personnes qui auront un patrimoine génétique qui vont, que ça va craquer, qui vont se retrouver très rapidement dans l'hyperphagie, dans la boulimie et un petit nombre dans l'anorexie mentale.
Et puis, il y en a d'autres qui vont le supporter. Il y a des différences biologiques qu'il faut pouvoir accepter. Il y a des différences entre les personnes de corpulence, de taille, de culture.
Il y a des différences. Si nous n'acceptons pas ces différences, on se met en situation de difficulté.
Alors, on va enchaîner sur une question peut-être beaucoup plus sombre.
J'ai pu lire que l'anorexie en particulier, et donc les troubles du comportement alimentaire de manière générale, étaient voilà, ce que j'avais lu étant comme étant les maladies mentales avec le plus de décès. Pourquoi ?
On l'explique, il y a deux éléments de décès. C'est le décès lié à dénutrition et une distribution très rapide chez un jeune adolescent, ça peut donner un arrêt cardiaque.
D'accord.
Quand c'est profond.
Hein, donc il faut faire attention.
Ou bien, c'est-à-dire que les personnes qui sont en état de dénutrition pendant des périodes très longues, de très forte dénutrition, ils perdent de la masse osseuse et donc ils perdent de la moelle hématopoïétique dans laquelle se forment
notamment les globules blancs et toute l'immunité et donc peuvent décéder d'une infection pulmonaire, par exemple.
Mais la moitié des décès, ce sont des suicides.
D'accord, oui. Donc c'est lié alors avec un caractère dépressif de...
Dépressif, non. C'est la moyenne d'âge des personnes qui meurent d'anorexie mentale, c'est trente-quatre ans.
OK.
Et donc l'idée, c'est qu'elles se trouvent dans un sentiment d'impasse de vie. Hein, c'est qu'elles sont dans la solitude, dans la difficulté sociale.
Et donc, ce sont en quelque sorte, oui, des suicides dépressifs, mais aussi, je pense, des suicides existentiels, elles en ont ras-le-bol.
Oui, on est dans une situation où c'est la fameuse phrase de corrélation n'est pas causalité.
Corrélation n'est pas causalité.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc, il y a donc des profils, vous parliez de comorbidité, qui peuvent donc avoir des troubles du comportement alimentaire, mais ce ne serait pas alors la seule difficulté que ces personnes connaîtront.
Tout à fait.
Et donc voilà, pour certaines personnes, mais donc de nombreuses personnes, visiblement, puisque c'est, je le disais, la catégorie des maladies mentales qui connaissent le plus de décès.
Donc de nombreuses personnes alors vont être en situation de trouble du comportement alimentaire, mais ce ne sera pas forcément la cause du suicide alors.
C'est ça. Et donc ça veut dire qu'il y a deux recommandations. Hein, la première, on en a déjà suffisamment parlé, hein, c'est de s'alimenter régulièrement et c'est de travailler à son réseau social.
On ne parle pas de Facebook, oui, c'est ça.
Les relations sociales, c'est très important, hein, parce que c'est ça qui impacte directement la confiance en soi et l'estime de soi.
Mh. Mh. Mh.
Hein, c'est l'attitude des autres à notre égard sur laquelle la confiance en soi se bâtit, sur nos succès, nos échecs, mais aussi sur l'attitude des autres à notre égard.
Et ces critiques dont on parlait là tout à l'heure, effectivement, ça reste dans la tête jusqu'à l'âge de trente, quarante, cinquante ans.
Si on revient sur la question des aides qui sont proposées aux personnes concernées, est-ce qu'on peut espérer, voilà, que ces personnes, les personnes concernées soient proprement aidées, encadrées ?
Est-ce que c'est le cas en Belgique, en France ? Quelle est la situation aujourd'hui, de manière générale ?
Non, l'encadrement n'est pas suffisant. Vous savez, c'est d'abord des problématiques qui ont été sous-estimées et qui se sont révélées, notamment dans la pandémie du Covid.
On a vu augmenter fortement les troubles alimentaires pendant le Covid. Et donc, ça a conduit à s'y intéresser peut-être de manière plus importante, mais il manque de structures de soins et de thérapeutes formés à ces problématiques.
Est-ce que les psychologues, lors de leurs études, sont formés sur la question ?
Très peu, très, très peu. Très peu, très peu.
OK. Ben est-ce qu'on a terminé alors sur la question des aides, des encadrements ? Est-ce qu'Allison, t'as quelque chose à ajouter sur la question des aides que tu as reçues ou bien est-ce qu'on passe à autre chose ?
Non, moi, c'était plus par rapport, effectivement, parce que je trouve que les troubles du comportement alimentaire, c'est peut-être le point, parce que
le problème central, OK, il y a la nourriture, mais en fait, finalement, moi, c'est ce qu'une,
c'est ce que-- j'avais vu une fois avec ma psy, c'est la détresse dans laquelle on se met.
Parce que la nourriture est constamment-- et en fait, on ne peut pas se rendre compte tant qu'on le vit, mais la nourriture est constamment en nous.
Mais c'est comme si vous aviez une petite voix intérieure qui vous répète inlassablement : Tu peux, tu ne peux pas manger, tu ne peux pas manger, tu es trop grosse.
Moi, je sais que j'en étais venue à faire des cauchemars. Et les cauchemars, en fait, c'est juste que je mangeais dans mon rêve.
Et j'étais soulagée en me réveillant : T'as rien mangé. Et en fait, c'est tellement-- non, mais c'est rigolo, mais bon, quand on le vit, un peu moins.
Non, c'est tragique.
C'est assez imagé, mais le truc, c'est que c'est perpétuellement là. Et en fait, à un moment, on a envie que ça s'arrête.
Et en plus de ça, ça a tendance à nous enfermer. Moi, je sais que les périodes où j'étais le plus malade, je ne voulais voir personne parce que voir du monde, c'était aussi prendre le risque de voir à manger.
Et comme justement, je passais ma vie à me dire : Tu n'as pas le droit de manger, je voyais un paquet de gâteaux, ben j'avais envie de lui faire la fête au paquet de gâteaux.
Or, je ne voulais pas. Donc, qu'est-ce que je fais ? Ben, je restais chez moi. Oui, sauf qu'à partir d'un moment, en fait, c'est le serpent qui se mord la queue.
Et ça amène, oui, des pensées suicidaires. Complètement. Complètement.
D'accord, donc tu, tu es passée par là, oui.
Oui, complètement. Et je trouve que c'est le point dont on ne parle pas forcément beaucoup, parce que oui, on a tendance à voir une personne maigre et à voir le problème, vraiment l'aspect nutritionnel, par exemple, sur une anorexique.
Mais non, en fait, il y a toute la souffrance psychique qui prend une place énorme.
Ok, une réaction, Docteur ?
Oui, je voudrais quand même faire une petite remarque. On a beaucoup parlé des comorbidités, mais il y a quelque chose dont on ne parle pas suffisamment, c'est que si les préoccupations corporelles,
c'est au cœur, hein, ou les perceptions corporelles, c'est au cœur des troubles alimentaires.
Par contre, les préoccupations alimentaires, c'est lié à la dénutrition. C'est pas lié à l'anorexie ou à la boulimie, c'est lié à la dénutrition.
C'est pour ça que la priorité, chez les personnes qui ont un trouble alimentaire, c'est de restaurer le poids, parce que c'est très clair.
Dès le moment où le poids se restaure, les préoccupations alimentaires diminuent fortement. Les préoccupations corporelles restent, la confiance en soi,
les relations interpersonnelles, le perfectionnisme, ce sont des traits de caractère qui restent et qui peuvent poser des problèmes à la personne.
Mais les préoccupations alimentaires, c'est en lien avec la dénutrition.
Et donc, résoudre ce problème de dénutrition, donc ça impose alors d'obliger, de forcer la personne concernée à restaurer son poids et à manger, ce qui est justement ce que la personne souhaite éviter à tout prix.
On est maintenant dans des stratégies plus collaboratives.
D'accord, oui.
C'est-à-dire que si on explique à la personne comment ça marche, peut-être qu'ayant une compréhension de comment ça marche, elle va pouvoir faire des efforts pour restaurer une alimentation plus adéquate.
Et l'expérience qu'elle va faire de cette alimentation plus adéquate, le bénéfice qu'elle va retirer de cela, le problème, c'est qu'elle ne veut pas l'avoir immédiatement.
Dès le moment où elle va faire l'effort de s'alimenter, elle sera plus dans la panique.
Mais si elle est encouragée à le faire par son entourage ou dans le cas d'une thérapie, c'est pour ça que ce sont des thérapies à fréquence plus élevée en début de réalimentation.
Si elle est soutenue dans les efforts qu'elle doit faire, à un moment donné, elle va identifier les bénéfices. Un premier bénéfice, on en a parlé, c'est l'arrêt des accès hyperphagiques, hein, des boulimies.
Mais un deuxième bénéfice chez la plupart, et c'est ça qui les motive d'ailleurs à s'engager dans le traitement, ce qui était bien souligné, c'est que ça devient insupportable, ces ruminations alimentaires.
Or, ça, c'est une conséquence de la dénutrition. Très clairement. Ça a été très bien démontré.
Allison, toi, tu as fait le choix, donc, on l'a dit, d'en parler publiquement. Est-ce que ça a été facile pour toi ?
Comment est-ce que c'était venu ?
Alors non, ça a été extrêmement difficile à l'époque, mais justement, je sais que je l'ai fait en deux mille dix-sept. Je l'ai fait... après, je suis sur les réseaux sociaux, j'expose ma vie sur les réseaux sociaux depuis deux mille douze.
Donc ça fait pas mal d'années. Et à ce moment-là, en fait, j'étais arrivée dans une telle détresse. C'est un sujet en fait que je voulais amener depuis longtemps parce que j'avais conscience que j'avais une communauté.
Je savais que ça pouvait aider. Et moi-même, en fait, en parlant de tout ça autour de moi, à quelques personnes de confiance petit à petit, ça m'a énormément aidée et impactée positivement.
Et je me suis dit que si je pouvais aussi avoir cet impact-là, parce que finalement, à l'instant où j'ai parlé de ça, ça faisait... mais ça, la nourriture et mes excès comme mes privations, gouvernaient totalement ma vie, en fait.
Je faisais tout en fonction de la nourriture et de : je dois manger, je ne dois pas manger, je dois perdre du poids. Et
donc, je suis arrivée, oui, à une phase où c'était pour moi assez évident d'en parler parce que je savais que ma parole pouvait avoir un poids, que ça pouvait aider.
D'ailleurs, ce qui est drôle, c'est que depuis ce moment-là, j'ai gardé contact avec certaines personnes.
Elles ont commencé à se confier à moi et en fait, des années plus tard, on se donne toujours des nouvelles, on s'en parle toujours.
Je sais que ça les aide et moi aussi, ça peut m'aider à certains moments, donc c'est avec plaisir. Mais c'est vrai que ça a été compliqué, en fait.
Ça a été compliqué, surtout par rapport au regard des autres, mais surtout les autres que je connais, que je côtoie, mais par exemple, des gens qui vont me croiser de temps en temps à certaines soirées, que je vais croiser en ville.
Le regard des inconnus, quelque part, je m'en fiche. Et puis, j'ai jamais eu de commentaires négatifs à propos de ces vidéos-là, mais c'est vraiment... ou même des personnes de ma famille qui ne sont pas au courant.
Et là, c'est un petit peu... C'est une révélation. Et donc c'est ça. Puis, j'ai pas envie d'avoir de questions, j'ai pas forcément envie d'en parler, mais je sais que lorsque j'ai fait cette vidéo, il y a quelques années,
parfois, les mois, les semaines qui ont suivi, j'ai certaines personnes que je connaissais à peine, hein, que je voyais juste de temps en temps, qui sont venues m'en parler en me disant : « Ben
moi, ma sœur a ce souci-là ou ma mère a eu ce souci-là.
Ben, j'ai beaucoup aimé ta vidéo. » Et c'était finalement, à chaque fois, ça a été des remarques très gentilles, mais on en vient au même point.
On a honte de notre état et on n'a pas envie d'être associé à ça, tout simplement. Mais je sais que moi, ça pouvait aider, donc c'est pour ça que je l'ai exposé.
Et aussi parce qu'à ce moment-là, peut-être, c'était un peu thérapeutique pour moi. Ça m'a aidée.
C'est ça, oui. Tu disais que ça a été très difficile d'en parler. T'as eu des difficultés par rapport au regard que les différentes personnes que tu as évoquées pouvaient poser sur toi.
Et du coup, pourquoi l'avoir fait ? Tu dis que ça t'a aidée. Ça t'a aidée à quel niveau, cette prise de parole ?
Ça m'a aidée parce que ça a pu peut-être parfois mettre un peu les choses au clair. Je sais qu'au-delà de ça, mes amis, à ce moment-là,
le mot n'était pas posé, mais ils voyaient bien qu'il y avait un souci en me côtoyant, ben juste en passant des week-ends avec moi, des soirées et autres.
Certains ont vite vu le problème. Donc, il y a eu aussi cette... Comment... Le fait de le dire, ça m'a évité des questions.
Puisque bon, mis à part si on est un peu indélicat, voilà, maintenant... Et c'est vrai que cette vidéo, après, bizarrement, quand je l'ai faite, je me suis dit : « Bon, elle va être vue par les personnes qui me suivent. »
Mais, et ça, c'est encore quelque chose de très actuel. Je pars toujours du principe que ce que je poste, ce que je dis sur les réseaux, c'est vu par mes abonnés, mais que mes amis n'ont pas mes réseaux sociaux.
Enfin si, si, si. Donc après, parfois, j'ai des petites remarques, mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait cette chose-là. Et puis aussi,
le fait d'en parler publiquement, j'ai eu énormément de témoignages et c'est quelque chose qui m'a aidée dans le sens où
je trouve qu'on vit mieux la maladie quand on est soutenue et que surtout, on voit que d'autres personnes sont dans le même cas.
Moi, je sais que parfois, j'ai pu regarder des vidéos qui traitaient tout ça. Et en fait, quand j'entendais les filles en parler, enfin certaines personnes, je me disais : « Mais on dirait moi. »
Et se sentir,
se sentir comprise, en fait, ça aide beaucoup, je trouve. C'est pour ça que j'en ai parlé, en fait. Je savais que je pouvais aider
et je sais que mes réseaux sociaux, c'est aussi pour ça que je les ai ouverts à la base, c'était pour du partage.
Et si je peux aider certaines personnes, peu importe le domaine, ben c'est une victoire, en fait, c'est quelque chose de super cool.
Donc c'est en ça que j'ai voulu... Et puis ouais, j'étais vraiment dans une impasse, donc c'était le moment ou jamais pour le faire.
Ça t'a fait du bien à toi. Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi une démarche pédagogique de ta part de vouloir informer à ce sujet ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des idées reçues au sujet des troubles du comportement alimentaire que, voilà, que tu as voulu défaire, qui peut-être t'ont agacée ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des choses à ce sujet ?
Alors, des idées reçues, je ne sais pas, mais c'est vrai que parfois, les gens emploient le mot boulimique un peu trop facilement.
J'ai déjà eu des... alors des, non, pas des amis, des connaissances qui, parce qu'elles avaient envie de bien se faire voir.
« Ah oui, moi aussi, je suis boulimique. Parfois, je mange quatre gâteaux d'un coup. » Waouh ! Non, non, non, non, non, non.
Les autres idées reçues, c'est que, par exemple, dans un épisode hyperphagique, on ne va pas avoir tendance à... alors, on peut manger des aliments qui nous font plaisir,
mais je peux vous assurer aussi que tout y passe, même des choses complètement abjectes
qu'on ne mangerait pas en temps normal.
Il y a ce truc de combler un vide, vraiment. Donc c'est vraiment tout ce qu'on trouve, tout ce qu'on a sous la main.
Mais pour moi, en tout cas, une des idées reçues, si on peut dire, c'est que oui, une crise hyperphagique, c'est pas forcément avec des aliments qu'on aime et c'est des quantités gargantuesques.
C'est pas un paquet de gâteaux, c'est pas deux paquets de gâteaux. Non, non, non. C'est des douleurs au niveau de l'abdomen et on n'a même pas idée.
C'est très douloureux. Moi, je me souviens de certains épisodes, je sais même pas comment j'ai fait pour survivre à ça.
Parce que j'en ai honte aujourd'hui de le dire, mais je pouvais même pas me baisser tellement, en fait, j'étais pleine.
C'est, 'fin, des douleurs, on n'imagine pas, parce que l'être humain est pas fait pour manger autant, surtout compte tenu d'un temps aussi court.
Et c'est vrai que ouais, ça, c'est peut-être une des idées reçues qui, moi, peuvent, pas m'agacer, mais qui, voilà, parfois me font un peu sourire.
Une crise de boulimie, c'est quelque chose de très violent. C'est vraiment violent. C'est pas : je mange trois gâteaux et ouh là là, j'ai trop mangé ce soir.
Non, non, c'est vraiment le stade au-dessus. En tout cas pour moi.
Docteur, donc, t'as des réactions par rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit ?
On a beaucoup parlé de l'alimentation et il y a ce deuxième point qui était souligné ici, c'est l'entourage. C'est favoriser la communication avec l'entourage.
Donc, si, au niveau des traitements, ce sont les deux axes importants : favoriser l'alimentation régulière pour arrêter les accès hyperphagiques et chez les personnes qui doivent reprendre du poids,
dans une procédure, on les aide à se réalimenter,
parce que pour éviter les préoccupations alimentaires, mais on ne peut pas traiter les troubles alimentaires sans intégrer, et c'est souvent possible, les proches dans les procédures thérapeutiques.
Alors, quand ce sont des jeunes de douze, treize, quatorze ans, ben les parents peuvent avoir des rôles importants dans l'aide à la renutrition.
Quand ce sont des jeunes adultes et des adultes, ce sont des conjoints ou des amis, ils ne doivent pas trop s'occuper de l'alimentation.
Mais ce qui est important, c'est que la communication puisse se faire et notamment, dans les moments difficiles, c'est extrêmement important, donc c'est de travailler les relations interpersonnelles.
Et juste une réaction par rapport à ce qui a été dit sur les... elle parlait des douleurs que ça pouvait entraîner, voilà, les crises d'hyperphagie.
Je suis désolé de revenir là-dessus, mais donc la question des décès. Vous expliquez que les décès survenaient principalement lors d'épisodes où on ne se nourrissait vraiment pas assez.
Est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des décès lors de crises d'hyperphagie aussi ?
Oui, c'est assez exceptionnel. On peut avoir une déchirure de l'estomac.
Ouais, OK. Donc peut-être une question qui se destine à vous deux. Pour les personnes qui nous écoutent et qui ont dans leur entourage des personnes qui sembleraient peut-être avoir des
troubles du comportement alimentaire, mais qui, voilà, comme on le disait tout à l'heure, le cachent, n'en parlent pas.
Est-ce que vous avez des conseils, donc pour les personnes de l'entourage, comment elles peuvent intervenir, comment elles peuvent gérer ça, puisque la personne n'a souvent pas du tout envie qu'on intervienne, justement. Allison.
Effectivement, c'est quelque chose de très délicat et j'ai eu l'exemple pas plus tard que la semaine dernière. Mes parents m'avaient pas vue depuis juin et effectivement, depuis juin, j'ai perdu du poids.
Et justement, j'ai perdu du poids et moi, j'attends la remarque de mes proches. Elle est importante. Mais je sais que c'est pas sain.
Cette attente n'est absolument pas saine.
Pour valider votre démarche, finalement.
Quelque part. Et puis surtout, me rassurer. Alors moi, je le vois sur la balance qu'il y a quinze kilos en moins, mais je veux l'entendre.
Parce que pour moi, c'est une satisfaction, mais encore une fois, elle est pas saine. Mais justement, mes proches ne me le... 'fin, ma mère m'a dit : « Alors oui, je l'ai vu, mais j'ai pas osé te le dire ».
Et moi, là, je lui dis : « Ben oui, mais ça, fallait me le dire ». Ben non, parce qu'en fait, il faut pas juger le poids de quelqu'un.
C'est-à-dire quand une personne a grossi, on peut lui dire : « Ben, t'as grossi », même si certains se permettent, c'est un délicatessa, mais il faut pas.
Mais quand quelqu'un a maigri, il faut pas non plus lui dire : « Ah, c'est bien, t'as maigri ». Moi, je sais qu'il y a quelques années, une fois, une personne m'a fait la remarque : « T'as maigri.
Du coup, qu'est-ce que t'as fait ? » Et tout. Et je me suis mise à pleurer. Moi, je me suis mise à pleurer parce que c'était un moment où j'étais vraiment très très mal par rapport à tout ça et super malade.
Et je savais que c'était la conséquence, ben de ce que j'avais. Et elle, elle a pas compris mes larmes.
Elle s'est dit : « Elle a dû faire une liposuccion ». Ben non, j'ai pas fait de liposuccion. C'est juste que je me sens très mal, en fait.
Et donc voilà, la remarque est indélicate. Faut pas commenter le poids. Cependant, quelque part, oui, quand je suis dans une phase comme ça, moi, j'attends la validation.
Et donc ma mère qui m'a dit : « Ben justement, j'ai pas osé te le dire parce que je savais pas si ça allait être bien reçu ou non.
Donc, je t'ai rien dit ». Or, moi, dans ma tête, je me suis dit : « Merde, alors si ça se trouve, en fait, les quinze kilos, il y a que moi qui les vois et personne les voit ».
En fait, je pense que si c'est juste que les gens se permettent pas de commenter, bon voilà, ça me fait sourire, j'ai l'habitude, mais je dirais qu'il faut écouter sans juger.
Et même en fait, là, c'est... faut pas non plus prôner à tout prix l'alimentation saine. En fait, parfois, on mange pas sain, c'est pas très très grave.
Faut un équilibre, c'est sûr, pour éviter justement de prendre trop de poids ou d'en perdre, mais il faut pas oublier de se faire plaisir.
Et c'est vrai que parfois, quand une personne est boulimique ou a tendance, oui, à avoir des phénomènes comme ça et à compenser par derrière quand elle mange trop, on lui dit : « Ben mange équilibré, mange sain, mange sain ».
En fait, non, parce que quand on dit à la personne mange sain, on sous-entend, ben, mange sain parce que de toute façon, t'es grosse.
Et moi, je sais que ça, c'est quelque chose dont j'ai horreur. Une amie, justement, me l'a déjà dit, où elle m'a dit : « Ben non, t'es pas obligée, Allison, de pas manger pendant trois jours.
Tu peux manger une salade ». Mais non, la personne, elle devrait me dire : « Mais Allison, si t'as envie de manger des frites, tu peux manger des frites, t'équilibreras une prochaine fois ».
Parce que quand on me dit : « Tu peux manger sain plutôt que de sauter un repas », ben non, moi, je préférerais sauter un repas.
Et surtout, pour moi, en fait, ça valide le fait que je dois tout le temps manger sain parce que je suis grosse. Donc c'est un peu tordu.
Et la personne en face justement, qui n'a pas de souci, va pas du tout recevoir ça comme ça.
Mais en fait après voilà, le problème, c'est toujours sujet à notre propre interprétation et quand on a un prisme qui est pas terrible, bon ben en fait tout peut être mal compris.
C'est ça. Donc là, on parle vraiment des questions de,
voilà, éviter les commentaires sur les remarques via vite d'une perte de poids qui a été constatée, éviter de dire que : « Ah, mais tu devrais manger moins, tu devrais manger mieux, etc. » puisque ce sont des remarques qui,
même si on pense qu'elles sont, elles vont dans le bon sens, elles sont positives, font en fait beaucoup de mal, sont très douloureuses à entendre, etc.
Donc là, on parle vraiment de choses qui sont, qu'on peut éviter de faire. Mais si je reviens sur ma question de, voilà, moi, j'ai déjà été dans une situation où j'avais une amie qui, je remarquais que,
elle mangeait extrêmement peu et elle me confiait qu'elle n'avait plus de règles parce qu'elle était tellement maigre, tellement... elle avait perdu tellement de poids que,
elle avait une aménorrhée et c'était,
voilà, elle était dans une situation très difficile.
Donc là, voilà, on a bien posé, d'après ce que tu nous disais Allison, les choses à éviter de faire. Mais si je reviens sur ma question initiale qui était : mais comment est-ce qu'on peut aider une personne qui est dans une situation de crise,
qui a une,
une anorexie ou une boulimie très difficile ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire dans le... quand on est dans l'entourage pour aider la personne ? Si je vous pose la question.
En tout cas, sur ce qui était évoqué ici, je suis tout à fait d'accord. Les aliments sains, c'est une notion qui n'est certainement pas abordée avec les personnes qui ont un trouble alimentaire.
Tous les aliments sont bons, mais naturellement, il faut un peu s'organiser. Ça, c'est un principe. Mais autre point important, c'est qu'il faut savoir que les proches marchent sur des œufs.
Ils marchent sur des œufs. Quand on dit : « Mais tiens, je suis content, tu as meilleure mine. Oh, j'ai pris du poids. »
Alors que le proche simplement émet un propos de satisfaction, de voir que la situation apparemment s'améliore, en tout cas au niveau de l'apparence.
Ou bien si la personne perd du poids, oh là, tu as perdu du poids, c'est toujours vécu avec culpabilité. Donc, il faut qu'en quelque sorte que les proches, comme vous l'avez dit, prennent le temps de poser des questions et d'écouter.
Comment vas-tu ? Tiens, je te sens fatigué ou comment ça va ? C'est d'encourager la personne qui est en difficulté à parler, ne pas donner de conseils, ça ne sert pas à grand-chose.
Non, ce qui est important, c'est de donner son point de vue. Donc ce n'est pas un conseil. Quand les parents disent : « Mais je te trouve un peu maigre », ce n'est pas un reproche, c'est un point de vue.
Et donc c'est ce partage de points de vue dans
l'acceptation du point de vue de l'autre qui, avec le temps, améliore la communication et permet aussi à la personne qui est dans le trouble alimentaire de savoir : tiens, quand je m'adresse à cette personne, celle-là, elle est crédible.
Si elle me dit que je suis trop maigre, c'est que je suis trop maigre, je dois faire attention. Hein, si j'ai pris trop de poids, ben là, il faut faire attention parce que prendre du poids, c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus délicat.
Mais donc les proches marchent sur des œufs. C'est pour ça que d'emblée,
dans les thérapies, c'est très important d'intégrer les parents chez les adolescents et les conjoints et la famille chez les jeunes adultes et les adultes, mais sans leur demander
des attitudes de contrôle.
C'est pas cela. C'est de favoriser la communication et l'expression du vécu des uns et des autres. Parce que les personnes qui sont dans le trouble alimentaire sous-estiment souvent l'inquiétude de leurs frères, de leurs sœurs, de leurs parents.
Il faut aborder cela dans des situations froides. C'est pas au moment à table où on voit sa fille ne pas manger qu'on commence à lui poser des questions.
Hein. C'est au moment où tout le monde est plutôt bien détendu, c'est d'aller la trouver, dire : « Écoute, on va aller se promener parce que j'aimerais bien te parler de quelque chose.
Voilà, je suis inquiet, je vois que tu ne manges plus. » Alors peut-être que la jeune : « Mais non, il n'y a pas de problème, maman, c'est normal, tout le monde fait ça. » Enfin, je ne sais pas ce qu'elle peut raconter.
Mais ça veut dire que les parents prennent position. Ça veut dire pour la jeune fille : tiens, mes parents ont vu quelque chose.
Et donc, la plupart d'ailleurs, sont soulagés de cela parce que ça veut dire que les parents ont remarqué qu'il y a quelque chose qui n'allait pas.
Et souvent, c'est la plupart, ça les soulage. Et puis naturellement, une semaine plus tard, c'est dire : « Tu sais, j'aimerais quand même qu'on aille voir quelqu'un qui pourrait un petit peu m'éclairer sur cette situation.
Ça m'inquiète. » Et les parents sont tout à fait autorisés à amener leur enfant chez un médecin, chez une psychologue, un psychologue...
Il faut y aller progressivement par étape et pas d'un seul coup.
Par étape et pas d'un seul coup. Et puis dès le moment où la discussion est engagée, être, grâce à un professionnel, dans une évaluation tous les quinze jours et de voir un peu comment la situation évolue.
Et puis éventuellement recevoir des conseils et savoir qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en place. Mais généralement, ces jeunes filles ont besoin de ressentir l'intérêt qu'on leur porte.
Qu'on leur porte de l'intérêt, qu'on leur porte de l'affection. C'est très important. Donc, il ne faut pas que ce soit de la critique ou des engueulades.
Ça va tout casser, ça va à l'inverse de ce que le parent souhaiterait obtenir. Donc, il faut rester très calme, très bienveillant, mais en même temps très clair.
Écoute, là, il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas. On n'est pas sûr, on n'a pas le même avis. Mais là, moi, j'aimerais avoir un avis avec un adolescent.
Oui, oui. Question peut-être un peu saugrenue, un peu étrange, mais Allison, est-ce que toi, tu... Donc, on expliquait tout à l'heure que tu ne parlais pas du tout de ça avec tes parents.
Est-ce qu'en entendant, voilà, docteur Simon parler de démarches qu'un parent pourrait entamer pour aider une adolescente en difficulté, est-ce que toi, t'aurais apprécié une démarche comme ça de la part de tes parents ?
Je sais pas. Je sais pas. Ils ont toujours... Ils ont jamais remis en cause ce que je pouvais dire ou autre, mais je sais pas si je... Alors,
si je ne prends pas mon cas, je trouve les conseils tout à fait pertinents et effectivement, c'est vrai qu'il faut prendre les choses à froid,
et oui, ce qu'on... Malgré tout, pour moi, ce genre de comportement-là, enfin les TCA, pour moi, c'est les causes d'un mal-être qui est autre.
Mais il y a un mal-être de base, il y a un souci. Donc voir que les gens se soucient et ont remarqué, c'est plaisant.
Je sais que dernièrement, j'ai parlé avec une amie et j'ai vu qu'elle s'inquiétait et ça m'a soulagée. Donc oui, ça, je suis complètement d'accord parce que quelque part, c'est un peu une recherche aussi d'attention.
Et quand je dis ça, c'est pas du tout un jugement, mais il y a un souci. Pour moi, c'est une détresse et on la manifeste.
Certains vont manifester ça différemment, pardon, mais c'est aussi une façon... On a envie qu'on se... En tout cas, on a besoin qu'on se préoccupe de nous parce qu'il y a un souci.
Après, moi, je sais pas si dans mon cas, je... Non, parce que c'est un sujet qui m'a toujours mis assez mal à l'aise avec mes parents.
J'en parle pas vraiment avec mes parents. J'ai pas envie d'en parler très honnêtement. Je sais qu'ils peuvent comprendre, mais j'ai... Avec ma famille, d'une façon générale.
J'en parle beaucoup à mes amis, mais j'ai pas envie d'en parler avec ma famille. Bon voilà, après, ça, c'est mon histoire, mais ça me met mal à l'aise plus qu'autre chose.
Donc bon, si je peux éviter ça...
Ce qu'aiment les parents, c'est que leur fille leur dise ce qui l'aide et ce qui ne l'aide pas. Simplement ça. Ça, c'est déjà quelque chose que la jeune fille puisse dire à ses parents : Tiens, quand tu fais ça, ça m'aide.
Quand tu fais ça, ça ne m'aide pas.
Oui, oui. Donc ce que j'entends, c'est que ça fait du bien à l'adolescente d'entendre qu'on se soucie d'elle, de son bien-être et que c'est quelque chose qui peut être positif.
Et inversement, ça peut faire du bien aux parents d'entendre, finalement, comme vous le disiez, ce qui l'aide, ce qui ne l'aide pas.
Oui, oui. Oui. Ok. Et donc, mais là, c'était intéressant de voir que pour Allison, on l'entend que oui, ça peut aider les autres, mais moi, j'aurais pas du tout aimé qu'on entame cette démarche avec moi.
C'est un peu ça que j'entends.
C'est ça. Mais aussi, c'est vrai que le truc, c'est que moi, quand ça a commencé, quand j'avais une quinzaine d'années, en gros de mes quinze à dix-huit ans, parce qu'à partir de mes dix-huit ans, je suis partie vivre à Montréal.
Donc mes parents, je les voyais une fois par an. Et je suis revenue vivre en France en deux mille quinze. Donc j'avais vingt-quatre, quelque chose comme ça.
J'approchais de mes vingt-quatre, je crois. Oui, vingt-trois, je sais plus. Bref, c'est vrai qu'ado, c'était pas non plus une souffrance.
En fait, c'est assez... Ça s'est installé de façon assez pernicieuse et ça a été assez graduel. Mais c'est vrai qu'au lycée, alors, j'avais déjà... J'étais matrixée par mon poids et par le fait qu'on me trouvait grosse.
Alors que j'étais pas grosse, mais pour moi, c'était quand même le problème numéro un dans ma vie. Mais au niveau de mon alimentation et puis aussi parce que je mangeais avec mes parents, et globalement, j'ai...
il y avait pas de quoi s'inquiéter.
Ou du moins, à ce moment-là, ça aurait été bizarre de leur part qu'ils me fassent une réflexion par rapport à ça parce que ça allait encore.
C'était plus psychologiquement pour moi que ça commençait à être difficile. Et parce que oui, je vomissais quelques fois et ça, déjà, c'est pas normal en fait.
C'est pas normal. Mais je sais qu'à l'époque, je dis pas que ça aurait pas été pertinent, mais ça aurait été un petit peu bizarre.
Et puis finalement, les années d'après... Oui, d'ailleurs, autre chose qui pourrait être assez intelligent à rajouter, c'est que, justement, moi, les épisodes où ça va pas par rapport à mon alimentation, je fuis ma famille.
Je ne veux pas la voir parce que je ne veux pas les inquiéter, mais parce qu'aussi, je sais que passer du temps avec ma famille, ça va être faire trois repas par jour que je ne contrôle pas.
Et alors ça, moi, ça me met dans une détresse incroyable, donc je préfère ne pas voir ma famille.
Et du coup, finalement, mes parents m'ont jamais vue, je pense, au plus mal parce que c'est des moments, et je sais que j'ai déjà passé un an sans les voir, quasiment, il y a quelques années,
parce que je sais que moi, ça va me mettre dans une situation compliquée de : je vais pas contrôler mon alimentation.
Et je préfère encore rester toute seule chez moi. Mais bon, ça fait savoir qu'ils sont à la queue encore une fois.
On approche tout doucement donc de la fin de cet entretien. Énormément de choses, évidemment, à aborder quand on parle des troubles du comportement alimentaire.
On n'a pas parlé, par exemple, de l'orthorexie qui est vraiment un cas, un profil spécifique. Il y a plein de choses qu'on aurait pu encore aborder.
Voilà, le temps, malheureusement, est limité, même si on a pu parler longuement de plein de choses différentes.
Avant de se quitter, est-ce qu'il y aura des choses que vous avez envie d'ajouter, des choses dont vous êtes frustrées qu'on n'ait pas pu aborder encore, jusqu'à présent ?
Je sais pas, Allison ?
Non. Moi, la seule chose que je voudrais ajouter, mais en fait, c'est parce qu'effectivement, ça fait beaucoup de sens, mais je sais que c'est quelque chose que j'applique pas, par exemple, en ce moment,
c'est la clé en fait pour se sortir de tout ça.
Effectivement, c'est de faire trois repas par jour et de, en fait, de manger. Parce que plus on est dans la restriction, et ben moins ça fonctionne.
Même si la restriction nous rassure, ben en fait, c'est... On peut pas aller mieux tant qu'on n'accepte pas et tant qu'en fait, on,
on arrête le fait de grossir comme... Enfin, on voit le fait de grossir comme quelque chose de grave et d'insurmontable.
C'est vraiment, il faut se décoller du fait de... Moi, pendant longtemps, et c'est encore un truc que je peux penser, c'est grossir égale mourir.
C'est-à-dire que grossir, c'est la pire chose qui puisse m'arriver. Mais en fait, non. Non, il y a bien plus grave dans la vie.
Mais tant qu'on a cette pensée et que du coup, on est tout le temps à se dire : Je ne dois pas manger ou je dois manger ça, mais surtout pas ça.
Tant qu'on ne quitte pas ces pensées-là, eh ben, on s'en sort pas. Mais c'est vrai que, et c'est là tout le problème,
pour... Quand on est dans des phases de restriction comme ça, oui, on mincit, mais c'est pas tenable toute une vie.
Et à partir du moment où on mange un peu plus, on grossit. Et ça, en fait, il faut l'accepter.
C'est ça.
Ça, c'est compliqué, mais il faut l'accepter. Sinon, enfin, les restrictions, en fait, amènent que du mauvais, même si ça nous rassure.
Donc plus on accède, plus on valide ces pensées-là, plus elles seront présentes et plus on aura encore plus, davantage envie d'y accéder, de les valider.
Donc ça, c'est... C'est un tourbillon quoi. Donc il faut la démarche initiale de, voilà, prendre, consommer ces trois repas par jour, etc.
Et se forcer à en sortir. Finalement, ça amène à ce que les pensées soient de moins en moins présentes, si je comprends bien.
Ouais, c'est ça. Moi, je sais qu'à certains moments, ça m'est déjà arrivé de penser : Ben ce soir, je fais une crise, mais c'est la dernière.
Et puis demain, je mange plus et puis après-demain, je mange... Mais non, non, c'est pas tenable, personne ne vit comme ça.
Donc, c'est le souci en fait, on est toujours dans cette démarche de : après ça, c'est fini. Et puis surtout demain, ben demain, je mangerai pas ou demain, je mangerai deux compotes et ce sera fini.
Mais en fait non. Du coup, complètement.
Ok. Docteur, quelque chose à rajouter avant qu'on se quitte ?
Les thérapies sont différentes avec les adolescentes, avec les jeunes adultes et les adultes. Mais s'il y a des jeunes adultes ici qui écoutent, il faut savoir que les accès hyperphagiques, ça se traite relativement facilement.
D'accord.
Quand il n'y a pas la nécessité de reprendre du poids. Ce qui est difficile, c'est de reprendre du poids. Donc quand la structure alimentaire est en place, ça peut prendre quelques semaines, on ne demande pas à la personne de reprendre du poids.
C'est dans un second temps. Et là, pour cela, il faut qu'elle soit en accord avec la procédure. Autrement, c'est difficile.
Mais ce qu'il faut dire à la personne, c'est que ça en vaut la peine. Ça prend du temps, hein. C'est un investissement, mais ça en vaut la peine.
Ça en vaut la peine parce que dans ce trouble alimentaire, ben quand les personnes sont dans le trouble, c'est l'enfer, hein.
C'est extrêmement pénible, avec un profond sentiment de solitude.
Voilà un bon mot de conclusion, je pense. Est-ce qu'il y a des endroits où on peut vous retrouver, vous lire ?
Est-ce que vous avez publié des livres ? Est-ce que...
Oui, j'ai publié trois livres, dont les deux premiers ne sont peut-être plus à la page, mais enfin, les principes sont bons.
Le troisième, c'est sur la boulimie. En fait, les techniques ont encore évolué parce qu'on a acquis des certitudes.
Par contre, il y en a un qu'on peut conseiller aux parents : Comment aider votre fille à sortir de l'anorexie. C'est pour les enfants d'adolescents chez Odile Jacob.
Et là, beaucoup de parents sont très, très heureux d'avoir ce livre parce que ça leur donne un petit peu des indications à la fois pour comprendre et savoir ce qui aide et ce qui peut ne pas aider leur fille.
Donc, Comment aider votre fille à sortir de l'anorexie.
Comment aider votre fille à sortir de l'anorexie.
C'est publié chez ?
Odile Jacob.
Ally, toi, de ton côté, où est-ce qu'on peut te retrouver ?
Moi, sur les réseaux sociaux, du coup, principalement sur Instagram et YouTube sous le pseudo Allyfantaisies. Donc A, deux L, Y et Fantaisies comme les fantaisies au pluriel.
Super. Ben merci à vous deux pour ces septante minutes, un peu plus de septante minutes passées ensemble. Et on se retrouve alors dans une semaine en fait, pour un prochain épisode. Merci, au revoir.
Merci. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode de Septante Minutes Avec. J'espère que ça vous a plu. Je sais que c'est un projet qui tenait vraiment à cœur à Allison.
N'hésitez pas à partager l'épisode et à nous taguer sur les réseaux sociaux pour nous dire ce que vous en avez pensé. J'ai hâte d'avoir votre avis.
Pour d'autres épisodes de ce type, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et à remonter dans les archives.
On a par exemple pu parler d'endométriose, de schizophrénie et d'autisme. On se retrouve dans une semaine. Portez-vous bien.